نعم، انسَ أشبال الدب، يا إلهي،
نحن نتحدث عن نوادي الدب،
ونادي الجولف الذي يسرق الدب،
لقد
حدث ذلك في الحفرة الثالثة عشرة في
نادي ويستوود بلاتو للغولف خارج فانكوفر بكندا،
الحقيبة مملوكة لجيروم زينياك،
أنت متأكد من عدم وجود شطيرة فيها
تلك الحقيبة، أنا
متأكد من أنه لم يكن هناك أي شيء، لم يكن هناك طعام،
بدأ جيروم في اتباعه، ولكن
الدب الأنثى سحبت حقيبته إلى أسفل الوادي،
والخبر السار هو أنني كنت محظوظًا حقًا هناك حيث تم
التخلص من جميع المضارب، وكان المضرب لا
يزال هناك تمامًا كما ذهب فوق
حافة وسقط على حافة
الوادي، لذلك كل ما حصل عليه الدب هو
عشرات الكرات وكيس من الشاي، لا
يزال الدب هناك، لم
يطلق عليه موقع Golf Digest أعنف فيلم رعب في
الصيف مما يجعل لعبة الجولف تحمل الجديد
فرقة الكوكايين "
الدببة" في هذا الملعب ليست شيئًا
يعطس فيه منذ عامين، هاجم دب
لاعبي الغولف وألقى الكرة
عليهم، يا له من أمر مضحك أن جيروم
لم يتمكن من استعادة
حقيبته التي تم شراؤها مؤخرًا ولكن لا بد أن دب الجولف كان
منزعجًا من ذلك
من الواضح أن دببة سلة النزهة Yogi Bears تتساوى
مع هذه الدورة، هل
يمكن لهذه الفتاة
تحمل العلبة
الجني ميرفي CNN New York أجنبية